hello everybody and welcome to episode
number five of my highlevel free toplay
flipping Challenge Series whatever you
want to call it uh today we're starting
off at about 71 mil uh let's see here
we're at about 71.2 mil and our
membership has run out but I kind of
just realized we are sticking to uh
fairly expensive items anyway and we're
not actually using more than three slots
at a time uh cuz there's not actually
that many high level free to playay
items you can use so I don't even think
I need to pay for membership uh so we're
going to leave it like this so to start
off we're going to do a ring of nature
flip cuz again like look at that 1 mil
in difference uh we're going to go to
bed pretty soon but we'll leave an
offering for well let's see it's
actually going up now interestingly
enough uh it seem to bottom outed about
7.6
mil and I'll put an offering for may4
95 or 8450 and hopefully in the morning
it will have risen up and or 851 I meant
ring of
nature
851k 113 actually nah we'll we'll
underdo it just in case h 80 let's do
899k and
uh we'll go for six and uh the other
item I think we're going to do right now
is the monks robe top G another very
good one we've done in the past looks
like 180k in each one and and we'll buy
him for
6030 monks robe top
G and for 6030 1K sure and we'll use the
rest of our money
here uh looks like we can only forward
[Music]
three and with four mil ask SC we'll try
to find something for 4 mil and we'll
try the bandas armor set I haven't
really done this before but it looks
mediocre but whatever we don't have any
money just sitting in here Bandos room
armor set SK I believe is what we're
looking for oh sorry
LG
Bandos LG and we'll just put offer in
[Music]
for
51k
151k H 20 sure anyway we'll go to bed
and see how many of these buy overnight
all right we are back um unfortunately
we only bought one of the Rings of
nature but we did manage to flip it for
a 1.2 mil profit that is crazy guys look
at that $93.99 we sold it for and we
bought it for 8.2 mil so 1.2 mil in
profit the monks robes we profited 51k
on those still pretty nice uh but the
Ring of nature oh my imagine if we
actually bought all those over night
that would have been crazy uh the Bandos
armor sets have not sold yet uh but
that's okay uh next up we're going to
try the iron gold trimmed Set uh we
checked it on G tracker quickly and uh
looked like they had about a 70 or 80k
margin on it which is pretty good for
the price uh so we're going to try
buying them for about 901k and we'll go
for a fair amount uh maybe 15 not sure
if we're going to get that many of those
but we'll see and of course we have to
try the Ring of nature again um how
could we not after a 1.2 mil profit uh
it's definitely risen up a little bit uh
so it's up to 8.7 mil but we'll go ahead
and see if we can buy some more for
these even at 3 or 400k profits nice but
uh yeah see how that goes and uh we're
going to pull these out and possibly
just insta sell them cuz it didn't
really work at all and then we'll try to
find another item for that slot and last
St we might just put an offer for the
ring of coins uh this item never seems
to have as good a margin as ring of
nature all right we'll come back when
hopefully these have sold all right
we're back and uh things got a little
bit messy so we had to redo a few offers
here so we took out the armor set and um
The Ring of coins instead we went for
the hill giant club and the um Team team
Cape zero yes uh so in the team Cape
zero we got a 64k margin 10 of those
giving us 640k which is still really
nice uh the hill giant clubs only 26k
each so 260k in profit pretty mediocre
pretty amount of money invested that's
okay all right so we're going to go
again and try these team Cape X's um we
haven't done these in a couple episodes
but uh very good margin 100K each for
the price so we're going to go ahead and
valant go for 20 now I don't know if
that's going to really happen or not but
uh you never know if we buy all 20 and
get 100K margin that's 2 mil easily uh
we're looking at these armor sets again
uh this one is the LG one instead of the
SK which does trade a little bit more on
G tracker showing a 53k margin uh
probably could be better though and I
believe we're going to try the team Cape
zero again uh has a 80k margin uh these
do buy pretty quick I've noticed over
any of the other team capes so we're
going to go ahead and max out the amount
uh which is going to be like four or
five or something probably oh we can do
five perfect and we'll come back in a
little bit all right that was some
pretty mediocre flips uh the Ring of
nature which is pretty well broke even
on actually we profited 50k on each one
so 100K on rings of Nature and uh the
team Cape zeros we did get a 71k margin
on and four of those gives us
284 which isn't too bad we are still
making money which is good so uh the
Ring of coins is something that I have
tried a couple times and I'm still not
totally sold on it it's pretty expensive
for the margin you're getting right now
let's have a look uh could go from 14162
to like 14400 maybe could get a 250k
margin on it not really sure if it's
worth it but I didn't really have a
better item so we'll go for three of
these and last step I think we're going
to try the Gilded armor set LG this time
we didn't end up doing it the last flip
but this time I think we're going to do
it cuz it looks like we could get 100
150k margin on it uh which is good for
the price and these do trade quite a bit
more more than their SK counterparts uh
so we'll go and do for what four
five what was it again 4590 roughly and
yeah that's right and we can go for
about five or
six miscalculated we can go for six
there we go and we'll come back with
hopefully some better flips okay so
we're just back uh pretty quickly cuz we
did sell off the team Cape x's and we
did also buy all of the Ring of coins as
well so in the team Cape X's did get a
440k profit which is pretty good and
we're in the process of buying uh we
have half of the guilded armor set so
far and we did buy out all the Ring of
coins so we decid that might as well
just go ahead and record another clip
here and let's see what we should pop
them in for we're going to put them in
for
14387 which is going to be about a 220k
profit in each one which will be pretty
good and I think we'll pull out the
armor sets as well and pop those in
hopefully for 100k profit I think all
right uh we are going to put them in for
4775 which is a very good margin that's
about a 200k margin and yeah hopefully
we can sell those off pretty soon okay
so the Ring of coins did end up breaking
even once again so clearly is not a very
good item for flipping that's okay the
GED armor set however we did get a 186k
margin on giving us about 550k in profit
off of that item so after all of sudden
done we're finishing today with about 77
mil uh which I'm pretty happy with I
think we can probably finish this up in
three more episodes is my goal I'm going
to try to get a little more than 5 mil
per episode uh in the last little bit
rings of nature have been working super
well and um the same with all the team
capes we're going to try to find some
extra items to do but I mean it's just
kind of hard not a lot of highend
high-end endgame free playay items
anyway guys hope you enjoyed and I will
see you guys in episode number
six
n